you probably already know that there are
not seven colors in the rainbow I think
you've been picked out seven colors
because it was mystical it resonated
with seven musical notes and the seven
days that he believed God took to create
the earth you probably also already know
that colors are continuous and like that
projection artwork there isn't one pure
red one pure orange in a real rainbow
you see all the wavelengths of light
in-between but what you might not know
is that a rainbow doesn't fade out at
red and a violet the e/m wavelengths
from the rainbow extend just a little
way into the invisible bits of the
spectrum not far water will absorb
proper infrared and ultraviolet but you
can see on what's called an absorption
spectrum that liquid water will let
through and therefore refract into a
rainbow wavelength slightly outside the
ones we can see if you take a photo of a
rainbow with UV sensitive film you will
see another bright band below violet and
there are people out there who don't
have lenses in their eyes they can still
see with strong glasses on but the UV
filtering that the lens provides is gone
so they can see that extra Banton now
over there in the National Gallery are
paintings by Claude Monet who late in
life had a cataract operation that
removed the lens of his arm and there
was a strong argument that his paintings
after that were brighter and bluer the
result of the near UV light that he
could then see there is one more
question man why does water happen to
let through just the light we can see if
it was set up any differently water
would be a pipe to us we might be
blasted by hard UV light all the time
and life would be well very different
the answer of course is that it isn't
chance at all over hundreds of millions
of years our ancestors evolved those
abilities our physics means that water
happens to be transparent at some
wavelengths so sensing those wavelength
is an enormous advantage to life the
species we came from were much more
likely to survive with the ability to
see those wavelengths imagine if you
couldn't see to you rain so those who
couldn't see those wavelengths well they
died much more easily repeat that for an
unimaginable number of generations and
here we are creating our own rainbows
you